well hello there
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it's january 6
2021 and america
we gotta talk there is a lot going on
right now
uh as i speak right this very second i'm
sure many of you are
scrolling twitter and watching youtube
feeds and everything else
uh there are well i guess what started
as a
as a massive trump rally in dc this
morning this sort of stop the steel
rally trump spoke yesterday uh has sort
of morphed into
a bit of endless chaos there's people
storming the capitol building right now
it's getting violent pepper spray we're
seeing all sorts of
barriers be blown over and people
fighting and all the all the stuff
that we have been seeing over the last
two years now
ironically or or maybe obviously
at some level you know what we've seen
in the last two years is that usually
the violence
in almost every case actually has come
from the left right it's come
from the antifa people it's come from
the blm people
and those are the ones that have
destroyed buildings and attacked
institutions and attacked police
officers and thrown fire bombs and gone
into
residential neighborhoods and the rest
of it it hasn't been the trump people
uh it hasn't been the conservatives or
the scary right-wingers that have been
uh doing these violent acts and and the
media
of course and this is part of the
problem because the framing is what
makes everybody so
crazy the media somehow equates these
things
so you don't really see it when antifa
does stuff and they try to deny that
that has anything to do with the
progressive movement or what's going on
with the left
and then anytime any little thing that
they can sort of associate
with the right happens they blow it up
to make it seem like everyone on the
right
and all the conservatives are violent
and everything else
unfortunately what's happening in the
last hour is there there is actual
violence there's a lot of extremely
frustrated people right now i think
there's a lot of reasons
to be frustrated but everything that
i've tried to do over the last couple
years as i've tried to
be willing to talk to people from both
sides and tell you what i think and and
hear opinions that i don't necessarily
agree with that's all been sort of
couched in the idea that if we're going
to remain a civil society we
we can't be burning down buildings we
can't be attacking the capital and
everything else and i know i'm going to
have people that are just by saying that
you can't attack the capital
you can't violently try to overtake a
building which i would say if it was
people on the left or people on the
right i know that a certain amount of
people are going to be angry
and and it just is what it is so let me
just kind of get you caught up
on on a whole bunch of stuff that's
going on right now we'll talk obviously
about what happened in georgia yesterday
because this is
these were the two days that sort of
everybody was looking at the fifth
because that was the special election in
georgia
for the two senate seats and then today
with uh what was going to happen with
the
with the the final results in essence of
the election so
we'll talk about that then i want to
talk about th this crazy
uh proposal coming out of new york where
they're they're basically putting a
proposal out there where they can just
detain people
for whatever reason they want related to
covid and then there was an interesting
video that went viral
viral yesterday that i think i think is
worth showing because you know there's
so many of these videos where we see
these people fighting about masks
fighting about lockdowns all of these
things uh there's a girl who's a who's a
social media
twitter person by the name of ashley
sinclair who i've met in real life
a couple times and she was on a train
yesterday and some some stuff went down
i think it's just worth showing because
it sort of gets to the heart
of the how the online world the fighting
of the online world
has leaked into the real world which by
the way is something that i was
warning about about four years ago i did
a direct message that uh
online culture was becoming mainstream
culture and i think we're really
really seeing that at the moment before
i get to anything else though guys we
have
a new sponsor and uh as you know people
i am a red wine guy right you know i am
a red wine guy i love a glass
at the end of the night uh sometimes too
although
as marge simpson once said you know they
say you're supposed to have a glass and
a half of wine
every night i just can't drink that much
that was a pretty decent march
that was pretty good um anyway i've got
a new sponsor
and they sent me a whole bunch of wine
i'm totally digging it so i want to tell
you about bry
bonner private wine if you enjoy wine as
much as i do then you need to try the
extreme
altitude malbec from argentina they make
it up at these remote vineyards at about
9
000 feet altitude these vineyards are
miles from civilization
and the result is this inky beautiful
red wine
when you stare into the glass it's like
being transported to another place and
time who wouldn't want that especially
these days
they're also healthier than other wines
with 10 times
more longevity boosting resveratrol
and 90 less sugar that's the good stuff
that's in red wine so they tell you to
drink it
no dyes no flavor additives none of that
stuff but the best part is the taste
blackberry leather smoking a little dark
cherry
head on over to free thinker wine.com
great
website you'll find malbec from the
third highest vineyard in the world
that's 8950 feet and a lot more too no
inflated prices you're going to get top
quality international wine for about
half the price plus my listeners and
viewers get 50
off shipping today just head over to
freethinkerwine.com get yourself some
malbec
that's freethinkerwine.com and now back
to me i assure you i will be drinking
malbec at the end of the day if not
earlier
uh because it's gonna be a loony one
okay so
a couple political things to just talk
about right up front so first off the
georgia special election
was yesterday let's just throw the image
up because it looks as if rafael warnock
who was the democrat
has beaten kelly loffler that one seems
like it's in the books
he had 50.6 percent of the vote over two
million two hundred thousand
and uh kelly loffler who was the
republican who campaigned with trump
she got under two million two hundred
thousand obviously at forty nine point
four percent the other race which was
jon ossoff
uh versus david perdue john ossoff who
really comes across like
uh american psycho if you've seen that
movie he really who's the actor who is
batman
christian bell he really comes off as
christian bale in american psycho
there's something i
really don't like about that guy but it
but he is in the lead at the moment and
conventional thinking as it is uh seems
to be that that he will win this thing
uh he's at about fifty point two percent
right now and uh david produced at 49.8
what's interesting about the georgia
election which by the way i haven't
spent much time
talking about i didn't even i don't even
think i mentioned it on this show till
yesterday and i don't think i tweeted
about it even once till yesterday
because i don't like the idea that we
all have to be
so focused on other states
elections that's really not how the
system is supposed to work yes
each state is supposed to send two
representatives two senators
to the senate where we can deal with you
know the the country-wide issues
but this idea that that seemingly the
whole future of the country and if now
the democrats have complete power
that it hinges on what happens in a
georgia special election that
something doesn't seem right about that
like this isn't really how the system
is supposed to work unfortunately so i
didn't want to pay too much attention to
it
because i because it's not that it's not
important but the idea that
for me someone here living in in los
angeles california at least for the
moment florida how you doing
um you know that i would have to care so
much about a senate
election in georgia just does not feel
right like whatever john ossoff feels
about anything
really should have very little effect on
my life literally three thousand
miles away but in any event it does look
like the democrats are going to get both
of those seats which in effect gives
them
control of the senate and especially
now that it does look that joe biden
will be president um
that then they also have the tiebreaker
which is the vp so kamala harris would
also be able to
break a tie so democrats are going to
have a tremendous
amount of power that just is i didn't
want it i
fought for what i believed in and i know
you did as well
but that does seem to be it here i would
say um
you know one of the conversations that
we're having in the reuben report
community right now
i posted something yesterday because i
actually did go into the youtube
comments section yesterday which i i try
not to do that often
but i did go in and somebody posted in
yesterday's
direct message uh you know this concept
that i've been talking about quite a bit
lately
about how if you have sort of a whole a
god-shaped hole that you'll fill it up
with any anything
or everything and people will fill it up
with government right so someone
commented yesterday that they were an
atheist
but that they have much more in common
right now with the believers because all
the
atheists and the secularists they're
just you know they believe in politics
they believe in the state and the
government and that's really dangerous
so we've been having a really
interesting conversation around that
and the reason i mention that to you
right now although you should check it
out at reubenreport.com
is that one of the reasons that i'm just
not hysterical right now everyone's
hysterical like
it looks like the election is not going
to go the way i wanted right obviously
okay obviously but i my life
my existence it doesn't diminish the
importance of these issues at all right
like i love talking about these issues i
love
enlightening people about these issues
interviewing people about these issues
i'm sitting down with tulsi gabbard in
about an hour from now we're going to
talk about all this stuff it doesn't
mean that stuff's not important
but it doesn't encapsulate everything
that i believe about the world right
like i believe that there is something
more important
and and we've been having a really
interesting conversation about that
reuben report so i hope
you will join us so the other thing of
course that's going on today uh
right now and we'll throw to the video
is uh the giant trump rally so there is
this huge rally this stop the steeler
alley
there are there's gotta be that's gotta
be over a hundred thousand people
that are in dc at the moment as i said
there are videos breaking
right now showing that it's starting to
get violent and you just can't look i
get it
i get it people you you feel like the
election or a certain
set of people feel like the election was
stolen do i think something
really weird happened with the election
the federal
national presidential election i
absolutely do i just do and if you want
to call me a conspiracy theorist
or an [ __ ] or whatever else
you can call me those things i sensed
that something really was up
we had a media that for four years told
us
that russia affected our elections that
ukraine affected our elections that
trump was a russian alfred operative we
had an impeachment fake impeachment all
of this stuff
yet somehow with this election
mainstream said no no no no no we got
exactly what we want we're not allowed
to touch it now look
i'm putting that out there that i
believe something seriously went awry
i think that if we had an honest media
we'd be allowed to
look at these issues and talk about it i
think ted cruz is doing a really nice
job at this ted cruz who's a
constitutional scholar who studied
under alan dershowitz at harvard who was
going to argue one of the cases by the
way if it had made it to the supreme
court and it should the supreme court
just decided not to take the case
and then i think there's all sorts of
political reasons for that ted cruz is
calling for 10 days
to try to have in essence like a full
audit of everything i
it seems to me that at this point the
ship has sailed
and it's like so if you're the most
rabid trump supporter right
and again i voted for the guy i i
support the guy i believe
that he would have been a much better
steward to keep america
on the tracks of anything that seems
like
the america that we all know than what's
coming with these crazy democrats
because there is
because if you think that joe biden with
dementia is in charge of this
thing uh you're just missing the point
right we can see all of the bad stuff
kind of reappearing right
right now i would have preferred trump
obviously
but i don't think that storming the
castle in essence
um is is gonna do it so this is gonna
we're gonna have a really weird two
weeks right now right because trump's
trump's got to decide what to do here
now i it seems like he's basically out
of moves like
you know maybe there's something there
one of the things that i said all along
i said this publicly
and i said this privately was if trump
was going to fight the swamp and beat
the swamp and beat the
the media and and fight the culture wars
and all those things
he did it pretty damn well and he did it
for a long time
was he perfect would i have preferred
that he didn't tweet as much all the
personal stuff okay we all know all that
stuff
it's boring to repeat it and yeah
everyone feels that they have to repeat
all that stuff all the time
as if he was as if anyone thought he was
jesus it's like people are like oh well
you know we we just wanted him to do
this the other thing well politicians
aren't jesus their politicians are
probably the furthest thing from
from jesus that you could get right like
you got to be a pretty freaking flawed
human being to want to go into politics
because it's a pretty
it's a pretty dirty game but it does
appear that he's he's basically
out of moves but as i said from the
beginning
after the election although i was even
saying it beforehand um
did he come into this thing to to beat
them on impeachment
get the judges in all of these things
only to lose at the end
and maybe he did maybe he did maybe
that's the power of the whole system
i hope what people will realize whatever
happens at this point
is that something something is rotten
here if
if you think that government is just so
right and that when you get the power
you can do whatever the hell you want
when the other guy has it you have the
right to burn it down that's what we got
to get past
in america and i'll keep trying to push
that and and speaking of
burning it down there is some crazy
stuff coming out of
new york at the moment so there is a
bill that is in the new york state
senate right now it is bill
a416 which would put
disease carriers in detention camps
i'm not making this up i've got a couple
quotes here from reason
new york lawmakers are mulling a bill
that would allow the state to detain
anyone carrying or suspected of carrying
a contagious disease
that makes them a significant threat to
public
health the governor may order the
removal
and or detention of such a person or
of a group of such persons in a medical
facility or other appropriate facility
or premises designated by the governor
or his or her delegate a confirmed
carrier would release would released
only after he or she is no longer
contagious there's a little strange
english in there uh we've got it we've
got an
image of the bill i think right there so
you can see a little bit more
um but this is this is seriously scary
stuff like this feels like world war z
stuff this feels like i am legend kind
of stuff this feels like
v for vendetta kind of stuff i mean this
line
order the removal and or detention of
such a person
so such a person meaning a carrier of
the disease that the government
could say you're a carrier of this
disease we can come
into your house and take you and put you
into a camp but it goes on to say
something that seems
much more dangerous it says detention of
such a person
or of a group of such persons
a group of such persons what does that
mean does that mean a group of
carriers or a group of people who look
like a carrier
like this kind of feels like some weird
nazi stuff
and again i try not to use the n word
that n word
i try not to use the other n word but
the point is that
this type of thing like oh these people
we can take
these people away because they don't
behave the way we want to
and then it's like well well what else
would you do if
if this thing was passed would you be
allowed to not be a carrier but talk
about how you're against lockdowns would
would that be okay or would you be then
sent to a camp too
this is seriously dangerous stuff and
and in a certain regard
i could relate this to the earlier story
because the frustrations
that we're seeing and this is actually
going to relate to the third story as
well but the frustrations that we're
seeing with people
that are now protesting and angry and
yelling and storming the castle
or whatever it might be it's understood
like i understand the frustrations and
the question is what do you do with
those frustrations what do you do
when you have governments
federal governments or local governments
what do you do
when they're threatening to detain you
when they're telling you
we don't care what you think and if you
say that i want you to
you know audit this or signature match
this we're just not going to do it
or i have some questions about the
science behind
lockdowns or i want to be able to live
as i see fit
in my own home with whoever i wish to
live with
and the government ignores you or puts
regulations on you that infringe on your
rights well
you could see why people get justifiably
angry
that is not an excuse for violence and
and yet
i'll tell you this i understand why
people do get violent that's not an
excuse for violence
but people that feel like they have
nothing left that the government's
coming to get them it won't let them go
to work they have nothing else to do
that's not an excuse for it's not an
excuse in and of itself
i'm just saying i can i can understand
the psychology of someone
in that position people that are told
that they're the worst thing in the
world constantly and they're nazis and
bigots
and all of those things and you're not
going to let them go to work and
all of the rest of it and then you say
oh by the way we might put you in
detention centers
we might put you in detention centers
because you might be sick or you might
talk about some stuff we don't want you
to talk
about well all of this it feels like
everything of the last couple years is
kind of leading to all of this craziness
and we're going to have to figure out a
way to navigate through some of it in
in a sane way and and i'm not exactly
sure how we're going to do it but i'm
going to be doing it along with you but
this is a perfect segue actually
to the third story so this was going
viral
yesterday on the uh the twitter machine
uh ashley sinclair she is
a uh she's what would we call ashley
she's a social media
influencer she's a social media
influencer that's like a thing you can
call somebody now
i've met her a couple times she's a
lovely girl and uh
she was on a train and uh well
let's just take a look at the video
wow you have 70 thousand twitter
followers well they're not
that means nothing you're still being
very rude
these men
[Music]
you know what's safer than a mouse
social distancing that's more effective
than the mass so why don't you step back
and leave him you're right involved
yes i am because your father on this
train
with his mask off
would you like me to call the police we
have nothing if you don't want any
please
everybody needs to go back to their seat
she said i got 70 just go back to your
scene
if not i will call the police and let
the police handle it
okay so you guys know that there's a
gajillion of these videos by the way i
should clarify that ashley was the girl
taking that video the woman that had the
the camera there i have 70 000 followers
these people are drinking coffee
uh she actually follows me on twitter it
turns out she's a huffpo contributor i
have a feeling she doesn't like me very
much
but the reason i wanted to show you that
because we all know there's a ton of
these type of videos
but when i talked earlier about how
online culture is leaking into
mainstream culture it's like
now we're approaching people with with
phones and we see this happening all
over the place
to shame them right we're shaming people
and then i thought the line about i have
70 000 twitter followers like you better
bow to me mr guy
drinking coffee which you're allowed to
do on a
on a train which by the way the train
looks pretty empty and all of the trains
i'm pretty sure that was either long
island railroad or new jersey transit
which i grew up
riding those all the time the trains are
virtually empty right now there are no
commuters coming in and out of the city
at this point
so if this woman if this karen there
with her 70 000 followers if she thought
that coronavirus was so bad and so
contagious and so deadly
and all of the things right if she
thought all that stuff why didn't she
just walk to another train
and this is what i'm concerned about
about our sort of collective mental
health
i don't like collectivism as a general
rule i like individualism
but there is a certain collective mental
health that we have to have as a country
so that we can
we can be okay with living with people
that are different
those guys sitting there drinking coffee
uh guess what
they didn't get anybody sick and they're
not sick and it's okay you're allowed to
drink coffee i just was on a plane
all right i just flew back from florida
and they want you to have a mask on and
i was respectful when they wanted me to
have the mask on and then when i was
served food
because food can't go through a mask
although i'm sure the scientificians are
working on that right now
i would take the mask down and i would
do it i did and i posted about this
i did at one point keep my mass down a
little extra long with a small cup
of creamer coffee creamer pretending i
was drinking that just so i could get a
little extra air
anyway guys you see the point here that
we can't we can't get to a point where
we're all wandering around with phones
trying to destroy other people
and this woman when she says the 70 000
twitter thing it's like she what she
wants is those men to feel afraid i'm
going to destroy you
meaning whatever you're if i get you on
this camera i'm going to come for your
job i'm going to come for your family or
anything else
little did she know that ashley sinclair
i think she's probably got what give me
give me a number here how many twitter
followers i'm sure she's got at least
500 000 or something
like that she's there countering it and
that's the point
that's the point if we if we unleash all
of this onto everyone man so
ashley's got 400 000 over 400 000
followers
anyway the numbers don't even matter
it's not even that the specifics matter
of it but but all of this i think
i think in the 22 minutes that i've been
talking here i think what you're
what you're getting from this is we may
get election results we don't like
we may be living in a country with a lot
of people we don't like
right like i don't like a lot of people
right now i'm in la where everywhere i
go
people are in masks and nobody says hi
and i walk my dog and i say hi to people
and people just literally cross the
street or ignore me which is
i guess better at some level but but the
point is it's like we're going to have
to
put some of these pieces together and
and it's going to get
it's going to get way harder i think
that that is what's obvious
and uh you know i'll just say on like on
a personal note you know when
when so many of you found me over the
last couple years when the intellectual
dark web
thing was blowing up and you know there
was this this group of people of about
10 or 20 people that were coming
together and try to talk about some of
these things
i guess at some level we we
failed in some way because i think if we
had been able to to keep it together and
i think there were many reasons that it
didn't quite work out uh that maybe we
could have steered out of some of this
i i actually think one of the things
that that was sort of
unfor an unfortunate piece of this is
that when
when jordan peterson uh got sick and
he's coming back soon and his new book's
coming out in about two months and he's
been
putting some videos out when he got sick
and disappeared he was he loomed so
large in so many people's lives and
helped so many people find a little
order in the chaos as he would say
uh that that i think his disappearance
actually
ended up causing not causing some of
this as if it's his fault but i think we
needed that steadying voice and and
unfortunately you guys know how the
media treated him because anyone that
tries to
to build bridges instead of burn bridges
is treated like
a heretic uh anyway look whether you're
a trump supporter or a never trumper
or you're a lefty or a liberal or any of
those things
we got a we got a crazy two weeks coming
i just see no
i see no way around it and and i hope
that some calmer
heads will prevail i have no doubt a few
of you are angry at me for some of the
things that i said
just now um but violence violence is not
the
answer even if the impulse is violence
and even if you feel like really bad
things are happening and it might be
true that really bad things are
happening and it's really unfortunate
that we don't have a media
that can help us dissect those things
and analyze those things and and look at
those things
honestly it really it's really
unfortunate right it really is
unfortunate and if we did have it i
would find something else to do
i would still be trying to get into the
mba although i did go to the orthopedic
surgeon yesterday
and uh a bunch of you emailed me all
sorts of tips and tricks
for uh for a torn acl i mentioned that i
tore my sl a couple years ago and i
threw it out the other day
he does want me to have the acl
reconstructive surgery my acl is
completely gone it's not torn it's just
gone all together
he wants me to have it it's it's a
pretty brutal surgery and recovery i
don't know what i'm gonna do i gotta
think about it but i may be doing this
show lying down for a couple weeks in
bed which i guess would
be a nice mix it would be a nice mix uh
okay guys i got a hectic day of things
to do there's obviously a lot going on
uh as i always say try to stay sane and
my next interview later this week is
with tulsi gabbard who
again it was like man the democrats you
had a chance this was the woman that
should have been
the future of the party she had
basically the right set of ideas that
could have brought this whole thing
together
but you guys purged her and i'm gonna
talk to her about what her future is
i have a feeling she might have an
announcement or two hint hint
and uh and we'll see if we can find a
new collection of people
to make some sense of the world with so
thanks for watching
and we'll be back tomorrow